[Applause]
our next guests are just one of the
funniest coolest most loving and honest
thank you honest couples that we know
and together they formed hello bello a
place for premium baby products at low
prices with impeccable ingredients their
movement their mission i am so in and
they're doing something very cool in
waco texas and they are giving us the
exclusive scoop that's right please
welcome kristen bell and jack shepherd
i mean to hear a man
literally talk about
kids the way that dax does to hear a man
talk about
that level of love for his daughters and
the measure of his moral compass and the
measure of his mood and the measure of
his life and what matters there's like
an i would die for you
i will die if i get this wrong i will
die
like this is now what the purpose of my
life is i it was so interesting to get
that vibe
from dax there's more than enough of
this to go around so yeah
well you're financially independent so
we invite you in
and we both adore you this could work
this could really be something hard work
and we all love to laugh
well can i just say that i'm so sorry
you were right on the verge you're
coming out of the block oh i'd love to
hear what you would want to add
well first i would add a humongous thank
you but no i just wanted to say um
some things are way easier for me um
it's easier for me to be generous now uh
because i don't live in scarcity by the
time we had kids you know i was in a
position that's a lot easier to be in
than a 24 year old dad who's just trying
to make a name for himself somewhere so
you know it is easier for me i think i
just wanted to say that what were you
going to say
i was going to agree with everything and
i i mean i'm a big believer in like
forgiveness and second chances and so in
in the beginning it was nerve-wracking
dating dax knowing you know his history
of recovery and and that he's just this
big force but i was like no he's got it
inside of him he's got all his goodness
and i have been proven
right yeah because nobody is more
affectionate with our i'm not even as
affectionate with our girls as he is and
hopefully they'll grow up you know
healthier and happier and safer well and
in a loving throuple like ours yeah
first of all how to model love is such a
big
thing for me and i think also modeling
how to fight is it true that you guys
will allow
a kerfuffle to
occur around your kids and make sure
that you find the resolve and the
closure and the solution and not leave
it hanging so that they'll know how to
resolve things that was actually dax's
idea i love it it will definitely not we
don't play games there there's too much
data that tells us that the kids know
what's happening no matter how you're
playing it right they content they can
sense the tension they even with a
professional actress as a mom even with
me who's the best professional actress
we've got yeah
perhaps
globally um it's not always possible to
alleviate it in the moment because we're
too pissed at each other but he said
let's always make sure we do it in front
of them like the day after and so we
just model the behavior of conflict
resolution in front of them because what
what no one has really talked about much
is that you have a fight and then you
close the door and resolve it yeah they
see they learn how to get in a fight but
they don't really learn how to get out
of a fight or resolve a fight i love how
you have conflict resolution and you
admit that you fight as a couple
what do you do as co-workers if you
fight at work
you're gonna hate this
we've never fought at work it's like the
place that we are most harmonious
because it's the place where we both
have the exact same shared goal like in
daily life i want pizza she wants a
salad from some place but when we work
we have a very
unified tone we we think the same things
are good we think the same things are
funny
we also have a shorthand that recognizes
the other person's strengths or
capabilities or maybe where they're
faltering that day and we we we're going
towards the same peak this mutual goal
and dax put it so eloquently in that it
kind of brought a newfound passion to us
working together again we've done it off
and on but especially the game show you
get to see your partner kind of be at
their best and it's really sexy like
yeah like i was saying it's rare that if
you're married to an accountant he's
gonna bang a spreadsheet out in front of
you and you're gonna go oh what a genius
like you're not appreciated for the
thing you're great at but
i benefit from how great she is i mean
she's my favorite performer she's my
favorite actor i've ever directed she i
mean that's legit i can hate her in the
morning to be honest we're trying to get
in the car and she's got to make 13
different teas for herself and i'm like
this woman is the pits we get to work
i'm like this woman's a gangster man
you're gonna run this thing quick she's
only gonna need one take and i'm gonna
be the beneficiary of that
um
you guys are in waco texas
and
you are
running this extraordinary diaper
factory american made
without
the chemicals and with complete
integrity how and why did you take on
this enterprise in the next phase of
your beautiful company hello bellow
to be the first independently owned
diaper company that's manufacturing here
in the usa it makes us so happy we're
bringing
150 jobs to
waco and then all these exciting people
just jumped on board chip and joanna
gaines and magnolia came on to design
the facility and so they created a
facility that like was very it felt like
hello bella but it also felt like we
were planting roots in waco the whole
thing just came together seamlessly it's
only a step away from uh willy wonka's
charlie a chocolate factory when we
pulled up we were like this can't
possibly be a factory it's like a
quarter mile of our super cute clouds
and characters and blues and greens and
it looks you know it doesn't look like a
factory which is fun well you guys are
storytellers and when i think of you
guys
i am in obviously in the throuple sense
but i'm in as a consumer because you
guys keep it real as a couple dax you
know i love armchair expert and you
being a human being who is you're one of
our best guests ever we we got so much
incredible feedback from you people are
so blown away with your vulnerability
your honesty it was really uh a huge
swell of support and love for you and
i'm so relieved and kristen you know
you're anyone that shows up with four
drinks from starbucks as well with none
for you
yeah yeah not for us
i'm going to come in with three trays
[Music]
you